beaucoup d'émotion encore une fois parce
que recevoir une très large confiance
qui dépasse même les clivages des deux
groupes de la majorité
sénatoriale c'est ça me donne des
devoirs des devoirs d'abord de cette
confiance reçue mais aussi des devoirs
vis-à-vis de l'ensemble des groupes du
Sénat et de l'ensemble des sénateurs
vous savez je je souhaite vraiment
que le Sénat qui a un rôle particulier
dans cette période je l'exliquer à mes
l' sénateur il y a pas de majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale ici il y a une
majorité il y a une assemblée qui est en
capacité de débattre
d'amender de s'opposer de dire oui et je
dois dire que cette responsabilité là il
faut qu'on l'assume pour le pays en
fabriquant mieux la loi en contrôlant le
gouvernement et en n'oubliant jamais que
nous procédons de la trappe des 500000
élus territoriaux qui sont le ciment de
notre pays mais est-ce que sur le plan
personnel vous vous êtes fait une
réflexion particulier il y a cette
longévité 5èe fois est Liu à ce poste
qu'est-ce que personnellement vous vous
êtes dit que j'avais le même
enthousiasme que la première fois le
même désir et j'allais dire le même
bonheur et
que la 5è fois c'est comme la première
fois c'est une responsabilité que je
reçois par la confiance de mes collègues
vous avez parlé du Sénat point
d'équilibre de la République c'est ce
que vous aiez dit dès le soir de
l'élection sénatoriale du 24 septembre
vous l'avez redit dans votre discours
c'est quoi c'est ce point d'équilibre de
nos institutions et de la République en
quoi est-ce que le Sénat est
indispensable est-ce que vous diriez que
vous avez participé du changement de
l'image du Sénat aujourd'hui je crois
qu'on a tous participé les 348 sénateurs
347 en dehors de moi ils ont tous
participé par cette image de d'assembler
à la fois on va au fond des choses mais
en même temps qu'il y a des débats
et qui mesure parfois qu'il faut dire
non quand c'est l'intérêt du pays le
doyen tout à l'heure a emprunté une
métaphore maritime voyez je l'ai reprise
je crois que nous devons nous donner une
boussole et cette boussole c'est
l'intérêt du pays vous êtes élu pour la
5è fois au poste de président du Sénat
est-ce que vous avez un message à
l'exécutif est-ce que vous adressez
aujourd'hui un message en particulier à
Emmanuel Macron vous AZ entendu très
véément en concer qui concerne la
décentralisation il faut un nouveau choc
nous lui avons fait une proposition
j'ai renouvelé cette proposition à
s le président de la République nous a
renvoyé à certain nombre de réflexions
je viens de lui répondre et je pense que
ce sujet de la décentralisation c'est
pas simplement en quelque sorte pour
plaire aux élus c'est parce que notre
pays en a besoin notre pays ne pourra
pas se redresser sans ces territoires ou
contre ces territoires c'est pour moi
quelque chose de tout à fait essentiel
nous avons besoin des territoires certes
il n'y a pas que la politique
territoriale il y a un ensemble de
sujets que j'ai abordé dans mon propos
qui soit intérieur qui soi les grands
sujets de crise migratoire climatique
inflation problème aussi de la politique
de santé tout ceci le Sénat souhaite
vraiment aider le pays être à l'écoute
du pays et il faut que l'exécutif nous
entende partage et surtout respecte le
Parlement un mot sur l'un des principaux
textes qui va arriver cet automne le
projet de loi immigration qu est votre
approche puison sait que c'est le Sénat
qui va examiner ce texte en premier
est-ce que vous dites à l'exécutif de
retirer l'article
3 ce texte ce texte il est devant la
commission des lois il a déjà été
examiné chacun sait les réserves absolu
que nous avons sur les articles 3 et 4
je le redis c'est ma position nous avons
plus de 430000 chômeurs étrangers à un
moment où la question de l'intégration
est majeure occuponsous nous déjà de
reconduire ces étrangers qui résident
régulièrement en France vers le travail
et nous feront une bonne œuvre et pour
l'économie et pour l'intégration on
arrive à la fin de cette interview
gerérard Larcher si vous voulez bien je
vaouis vous poser une question sur la
Corse car le chef de l'État a fait des
annonces en ce sens jeudi il veut que
l'île de Beauté rentre dans la
Constitution avec ses spécificités
historiques linguistiqu et culturell
jusqu'où la droite sénatoriale est-elle
prêt à aller dans et bien cette
construction d'un accord avec les a du
corse d'abord je recevrai les deux
sénateurs cors très rapidement et je
recevrai le président
Siméoni la semaine prochaine chef de
l'exécutif Corse savez on a quelques
principes je l'ai dit dans mon discours
oui à la différenciation mais dans
l'unité de la
République